want to get right to this with my next
guest former acting ice director ron
vitello uh ron uh let's just start uh
with these these flights that are now
the biden administration pushing back on
i should note ron desantis governor of
florida also said there were 70 secret
flights last summer just in the
jacksonville alone
we're not supposed to believe our lying
eyes i guess on these huh
yeah don't don't believe the facts or
what you see with your own eyes very
well put so we've been talking about
these flights since the spring
and if it is in fact unaccompanied
minors who are being sent to shelters or
to sponsors or a family in the united
states why can't the administration just
publish the manifests to the states that
they're going to or to those airports
right those flights don't take off
whenever they want they don't land
whenever they want that's all very
regimented those contractors that are
employed by ice to bring those people to
those destinations have to file flight
plans they have to get permission to
take off and land at airports why can't
they just put that out so that the
governor's
members of the house can see where these
flights are going and what the volume is
why are they not doing that even though
we've all been talking about it since at
least the spring and all they've got to
do is be a little bit more transparent
so they can stop having this
conversation
about what what might or might not be
secret flights but they could just tell
everybody what's going on the reason
they don't want to talk about it but
they have to expose the volume of
activity that's going on in the border
that's been
created by the the lack of coherent
policy at the beginning of this
administration you know a paper from uh
just recently from heritage uh brings up
a point because as i'm watching these
videos and the one thing that that
always stands out as these young
strapping young men
look like they may be in their 20s that
are the type of people you need to
rebuild your nation wherever you're
coming from
and they're saying that the biden
administration by failing to detain or
remove single adult males
the administration is removing the last
disincentive to illegal immigration do
you agree with that statement
it's all about incentives and
disincentives and you it's absolutely
right if you if you
if people come to the border and are
released in mass all over the united
states they're going to send home for
more of their friends more of their
relatives and it's going to encourage
more people to come so if you look at
what's going on in the policy side if
you look at what's going on
operationally in which the border patrol
and cbp are distracted by the care and
comfort mission and the processing which
lets a lot of people come to the border
and get away they aren't even countered
by the border patrol many of the ones
that are being encountered are being
released and so you're encouraging
people from all over the globe to come
to the border now on top of that the
rhetoric around immigration enforcement
inside the united states is all
backwards too because the secretary
himself said that they're not going to
go after people in the country just
because they're here illegally well
that's an incentive if you if you make
it to a place like new york city or
chicago you know that no one's looking
for you so we saw this video i i suspect
everyone's seen this video uh with the
the border agents and leadership and uh
obviously there's a tremendous amount of
tension there what's going on
well
they recognize that the policies that
were in place before this administration
have been removed they watched in real
time the border implode literally they
have record numbers of activity when in
fact the beginning of january last year
we had record lows of activity at the
southwest border because the policies
that were in place disincentivized
people for come from coming in large
numbers and those agents are frustrated
because that traffic that comes to them
though the people that they have to
process they can't walk away from that
they're stuck that lays at their feet
until it's taken care of ron speaking of
frustration we just heard jackie
mentioned uh this this report that's due
on the the so-called
horse uh horse incident
uh
listen i gotta tell you when the
president of the united states accuses
an agency like the border patrol agency
of actually strapping to borrow his
words that's a serious serious charge
how important is it for the white house
to come out with the support and clear
the air on this
yeah they need to get the facts out
because i think the facts are going to
support what the agents did uh the
reporter who took that still photograph
said that no one was injured as it was
not an assault uh but you had the top
three in the chain of command running
down the border patrol and say that they
were going to pay that they were going
to have consequences so that's bad
enough right those three people that
made those statements they're all
lawyers they're law school graduates
if you wear the uniform of this country
you still have the right to due process
and frankly the rhetoric that went out
around that incident was not due process
they were condemned at the beginning and
that's wrong yeah i mean as an american
we would hate to even believe something
like that was true so they need to clear
the air for sure ron thank you very much
always appreciate it